well I'm one of these terrible terrible
people who is always always connected
and so I have a sidekick not a
blackberry because i think this I could
looks cooler but you know and i use it
for instant messenger and i keep in
touch with friends basically constantly
i had my email coming to the device for
a while but I stopped doing that because
it was just too much I get too much
email it was just overwhelming me and I
sometimes I just don't want to see my
email actually but it's it's it's
interesting because it's there's a whole
different way of thinking about time
zones and living and friends and things
like this so of course I travel a lot as
well so I see people in different cities
and things like that but it's a it's
really yeah it's changed my life a lot
you know Tibet basically to have I am on
the phone it's kind of an amazing thing
I have a
macbook i just got a brand-new and
actually my old one was getting a little
scruffy so and yeah i like it i'm a big
free software advocate and so sometimes
people want to know why I don't have a
linux laptop and it's it's my personal
challenge to the free software community
that I badly want one but there's a
couple things I have to absolutely have
to have I need a good calendar and they
don't have one yet and so what I try to
do to make sure I don't get locked in
any one platform as I use as much open
source software as I can and I make sure
everything I use is is saving its data
in a free format so that I don't have to
get locked into somebody's proprietary
format because in your really host so
yeah I love my mac though it's beautiful
beautiful work of art
oh yeah every day yeah constantly
constantly yeah yeah I've actually
gotten kind of good at it but yeah no I
mean I when I was walking here today I
was you know chatting with somebody and
I was actually chatting with my little
girl about Club Penguin which we both
play so we were we were discussing you
knows big events this week in
clubpenguin rockhopper came so some some
viewers will know what that means is
some won't but ya know it's really a you
know you have to be careful not to get
run over
well I think that we're we're finally
getting to the point where the web is
kind of usable on mobile devices the
iphone has made you know major steps
forward in that regard so I think that
we'll see a lot more usage of the
internet from mobile phones and but i
still think will it'll mostly still be
only read only I think editing Wikipedia
from a mobile device is always going to
be basically too difficult right but i
think it's a you know having knowledge
immediately handy is something another
element of personal technology other
than a mobile phone though it for me
would be my laptop which I carry with me
everywhere and I you know it's
increasingly easy to get Wi-Fi almost
everywhere and with some of the things
that are coming like wimax if it's a
successful technology will make that
essentially ubiquitous and actually some
people I know have a little you know
what would a video modem thing so that
they get it the internet over the cell
phone network on their laptop and I
think we'll just see a lot more of that
I think we'll continue to see a decline
in desktop computers it just it's sort
of silly to have a desktop computer in
my opinion you just carry your laptop
with you everywhere and I think they'll
get lighter and easier to to carry and I
think we'll see a lot of a lot of
innovative applications that that become
more and more reasonable and usable as
you can assume that other people are
connected so something like Twitter
which is a you know people can send
messages to their friends list and sort
of hold sort of I don't know it's
Twitter it's kind of a group chat kind
of thingy well that only makes sense you
know if you assume that your friends are
actually going to see the messages which
means that they're getting it on their
mobile device or they're going to see it
it pretty soon anyway and I think we'll
see more and more applications like that
you